foreign
right now we've got the minimalist home
tour this week this is number three in
our series you can find all of the
minimalist home tours including pictures
of all of our homes as well but this one
today is from Maria and we're calling
this one Alabama I think you titled this
one right oh what a beautiful title on a
clear day you can see forever I will say
this she's in is she in Finland uh she's
in a stone Estonia okay I love it Ohio
and Kentucky are the same thing right
can I please get a little Maria
I just saw a kitchen from Maria yes we
gotta work our talent man we got the
talent man we get rehearsals going so
that's the thing that struck me about
this was the view out her windows and it
was just so breathtaking gorgeous from
Alabama can you describe this for folks
who are just listening to the audio
version by the way if you're if you
subscribe to the video version of the
podcast we send these out to you every
Friday minimalist home tour from one of
our homes or from one of our lovely
listeners lovely homes what are what are
we looking at here so what we see here
is a kitchen that's got a lot of natural
colors in it you see a lot of the whites
and the walls and the cabinets
everything kind of Blends in so it feels
very large and open you've got these
gorgeous hardwood floors that make it
feel long and spacious and just a quaint
little table right off to the side and
the counters are very clear it looks
like you could very easily jump in here
and get to work doing anything you
needed in the kitchen or at the table
but you also have these beautiful views
from the window right above the
countertops as well as what looks like a
sliding door off to the other side so
it's beautifully framed between these
two Sky lines of just I I can't even
find the words to tell you how beautiful
it is to me this is this is one of my
favorites that I've seen so far it's
great it's one of the most minimalist
kitchens I've ever seen it's super calm
and clean and who needs artwork when you
have those types of views I mean you've
it proves that nature cannot be beat
when it comes to Art if you have a great
view I remember Ryan when you lived in
Montana at the the place with the the
mountain views like that was better than
any artwork that you could ever have oh
yeah absolutely it's funny how uh I mean
I know this is a has been said before
but I think I'm just now getting it like
art is trying to imitate nature yeah
that is and that's a great
representation of that it's inspiring to
me I mean yeah you've seen my hideous
kitchen if you have been it's not
hideous I like your tiles
blue we we bought this house uh from the
folks who redecorated redesigned or they
they recreated this house and rebuilt it
from the studs basically but one thing
that they did was make really
ugly
the tiles in the bathrooms and the
kitchen and uh for whatever reason it
was aesthetically pleasing to them yeah
but it was aesthetically panicking to me
oh man Maria I love the way you create
space for the light because those views
are going to be beautiful no matter what
you do with the space however it's
possible that some clutter there could
just distract from that I'm looking at
the way the light hits the floor yeah
you know I mean it just it just makes it
pop brings the whole Space to life
you can send us yours podcast at the
minimalists.com we'd love to feature
your minimalist space on a future
episode did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free